yeah welcome to this very video and
playing Grand Master riccardi from
Argentina let's see queens in yellow to
get the some hybrid twins Indian names
of Indian and oftentimes called the
power of variation is quickly taking on
c3 yet white forget a big center with
you for always like this kind of
position for white it's not easy for
black to play because white has this
quite substantial space advantage and
short castle as a sound somewhat strange
to be honest this looks like a like a
completely miss played damage from
blacks point of view ok let's get ready
to rumble this is already sacrificed I'm
not and spending time years is useless
ok Queen age 54 yeah I guess this should
be good initial roof of the tag probably
really needs to go no I thought King
just happen
yeah whatever okay if I take now and it
takes III mmm has got Quincy five of
course so I probably should trust
recapture is playing almost and Cindy
this they always have a hard time to
understand this but ok it doesn't really
seem so idiotic what what it or I am I
mistaken okay if I take Quincy five
maybe
yeah this is probably good
hmm
didn't really see that beforehand
yeah of course he also didn't see it
just very lucky that this is working
yeah the problem is after captured
immediately Hank d3o immediately is
hanging so it's it's hard to play move
either yeah this is so not what you want
to play you can maybe queen a try forces
yeah then i should play d5 yeah probably
d5 yeah you have now I'm in this
position which isn't fun at all this
instead of just refuting what he did I
need to play this now okay so it's equal
material at least so I'm not all is lost
here
and Luke h am
yeah i can go queen of three
yeah I'm not quite sure maybe and Jim
it's difficult to to really improve the
position for white it's really difficult
not sure if I should trade Queens but
I'm a bit down long time so don't want
to spend too much too much here
check
yeah he's got the batter and game not
sure um what don't didn't expect that at
all it's a Jackie is from foot back
reaction I'm not sure why did this at
all
and yeah I'm difficult difficult to make
any progress him I'm just passing but
don't really see a way forward
and I actually forgot that he can take
it yeah I'm threaten you looking to
bottom check no cousin ah yeah great
great white reasoning yeah just the
mouse slip just need to retake and yeah
I'm boss IAM but still a game yeah the
real problem was okayed was it was still
a game of course but he should never
ever survived the opening this is
unplayable just completely unplayable I
just need to play d5 him and this is
just terrible for black I just pile up
on the king let's say something like
that we can swing the room night f1 and
so on this is just very bad for black
and he doesn't have any counter play in
the center witchy witch she got after
the smooth Rock d8 is of course
excellent that he believed that he found
this with this idea also the only
defense really i think but good warning
here i should release a wife I mean that
still was a game it's just because he
didn't play this one though after that I
don't have a move rock before as a big
threat let's say I take then he's
threatening to to do it is cover check
and term this one as well just over yeah
this was was still a game I mean I can
also take on g5
and and play play play from there this
is the best one katia the social plane
immediately equalizer because i get rid
of the week porn this is this is just
okay for white yeah yeah yeah i was
still too irritated that that i didn't
punish him for this i must play d5 queen
h5 is just bad i mean okay i didn't i
didn't really solve this move of course
very strong yeah and after d5 he's just
in trouble I think why this is clearly
better the computer just says it equal
but the computer does not really get
this kind of position it just took two
closed equal because of the various
Perpetual's that I have in this kind of
in this kind of information it's quite
easy to think about Perpetual's but i'll
just attack here I want to make it wrong
okay thanks for watching